in mandalay  a child has been killed  wrapped in white shrouds her tiny body  is making its final journey  [Music]  by her side her devastated family kneel  trying to understand how this  seven-year-old is gone why junta forces  shot her um  is the youngest person to be killed by  security forces since  the coup she should be in primary school  instead her father is carrying her  to her grave  as this father buries his little girl  his son is still missing  he says taken by the junta location  unknown  [Music]  activists say more than 270 people have  been  killed since the military took power in  february  more than 20 are children  young lives lost to an illegal crew  [Music]  siobhan robbins sky news thailand